tonight we continue our look at some of
the big midterm races by focusing on the
Ohio governor's contest
incumbent Republican John Kasich is term
limited Democrats and the GOP are
fighting among themselves for a shot at
gaining control of the state from
Columbus tonight correspondent Peter
Doocy
looks at two competitive primaries these
days the Democratic Party's kingmakers
are getting a run for their money
in Ohio the Democratic Party had an
insider pick but the people of Ohio want
fresh thinking Dennis Kucinich is
calling out his opponent in the Ohio
primary for governor Richard Cordray I
think we do have political differences
but I think a big difference is
experienced Cordray is a favorite of
progressives in DC from his days as the
first-ever head of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau we stood on
the side of people and saw they were
treated fairly in the marketplace the
Buckeye State back to Trump by eight
points two years ago now Kucinich the
former congressman Cleveland Mayor and
Fox News contributor is trying to show
voters that Republicans aren't the only
ones with solutions for jobs and trade
issues I have the ability to reach out
to Trump supporters we want to bring
them back into the Democratic Party a
pair of Republicans are trying to keep
that Trump coalition in tact lieutenant
governor Mary Taylor and the Ohio
Attorney General Mike DeWine both are
focusing heavily on the opioid epidemic
and the economy and both serve in the
Kasich administration but don't expect
to hear much about that I don't think
the governor is really a big factor in
this race at all even Taylor who was on
the Kasich ticket wants distance we
started with conservative solutions I
want to be very clear about this John
Kasich walked away from that
conservative governance and those
conservative principles Taylor can't
keep her staff Baylor is being attacked
for what her opponent sees as a lack of
experience if you go back and look at
what she has done throughout her career
it's virtually nothing but her campaign
is turning that attack around
I bring 16 years of private sector
experience Mike DeWine has no relevant
private sector experience so Republicans
are fighting about resumes as Democrats
fight over a message in the midterms my
campaign
is is about shaking up that Democratic
Party to make it respond to to the
people instead of just the interest
groups
I asked Kucinich if it was tough taking
on the Democratic establishment and he
laughed to say he's been doing in his
entire life
now the 71 year old Kucinich sees an
opening in a Democratic Party but still
trying to figure out how to win and who
its national leaders are I had a
November Brett Peter Doocy live in
Columbus Peter thank you